welcome back to New rockstars and pack
your bag spider kids because the new
across the spider verse trailer promises
to eat so many spider people across that
dang spiderverse indeed in this sequel
to The Beloved into the spider-verse
movie and this is only merely the
beginning because this is the first
trailer to this new amazing tale so just
think of all the spider themed surprises
that we haven't seen yet I know I have
and I think that the sequel to Across
the spider-verse isn't called beyond the
spider-verse for nothing people and call
me crazy but I think that the end of
across the spiderverse might just be
seeing a certain conqueror from infinity
and beyond
um cameoing at the end of this movie
this is Rogue Theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love and adore my name is
Mt and Gordon rugby today is the
wonderful Jessica Clemens what's going
on Jose uh today
[Laughter]
midday I love it and we have the amazing
Whitney van luningham with us today
what's going on Whitney tomorrow
tomorrow
then
tomorrow then right here and of course
we have the incredible Tom Michaels in
what's going on Tom if you've watched
spirited you'll get this but good
afternoon
that's uh not a spoiler but because they
that in the 1800s that's like a swear
but there's also someone's when he just
was like get out of here so and good
afternoon they're like
good afternoon everybody we have all
three ghosts from A Christmas Carol uh
today tomorrow and good afternoon
um
anyway everything [ __ ] everything's
exactly
but let us get on to our first topic
because across the spider verse has got
me so excited I cannot wait for this
freaking movie and the possibilities of
this opens up and I think
um a huge possibility here to at the end
of a process spider verse is that King
of the Conqueror well Cameo
um in preparation for Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars and here's why like I and
that's literally exactly why I feel like
he's going to be Cameo because we know
that the MCU is preparing a massive
massive Multiverse event and that they
are now partners and they're still
partners with um Sony pictures um
they're continuing their partnership and
um I remember from like a recent
interview with uh Kevin feige and Amy
Pascal is that they they were talking
about their they were working on their
next Spider-Man project with Tom Holland
with Marvel Studios actively
um and I think that there's a
possibility here that they could be
talking about incorporating Tom Holland
and um possibly even Toby and Andrew
into the third Beyond of the third
spider-verse movie beyond the spider
verse um and that Kang will be the
reason that everyone comes together
because he's gonna visit the spider
verse and be like oh this is pretty good
this is a pretty good place to conquer
I'm gonna tear all this down and make it
a nice nice bow for a sacred timeline
why not it's what I do uh but anyway
what do you guys think of this idea of
King cameoing in across the spider-verse
and continuing the partnership that Sony
and uh Marvel have have made with each
other cartoon King cartoon K let's go
it's true like we know that Marvel
Studios is going into animation now with
what if and uh now with the X-Men 97 so
like I feel like it's possible Jonathan
Majors needs more roles we need to put
them in more things so the let's get him
anime he's already in that new uh
fighter pilot movie he's in Creed I'm
gonna make those ass for me Daddy
no I want him to have more roles as in
bread so that he has less abs so I feel
less intimidated
he needs a role for each Absol 30. we
should pugify him and then he'll just be
a little guy
pug cake huggable King
red shaped cake
you know it's funny empty in the
beginning when you said yeah to infinity
and beyond it's like does he think Buzz
Lightyear is going to be coming into
a spider first I was like you know Mt
doesn't miss but holy sh holy [ __ ]
that's pretty crazy
comes back to the MCU as a Buzz Light
your voice or something I was gonna say
Tim Allen's gonna come back and and oh
my God the spider versus too woke bring
back the old times
yeah putting a Hydra weapon he's like
he just starts blasting off yeah
there is [ __ ] hilarious yeah exactly
but wait a minute isn't Red Skull Buzz
Lightyear just sir
oh this is true that's true
confirmed
oh I I love this idea though I actually
really like this idea because it makes a
lot of sense okay you said in terms of
like Synergy and um and and if you know
marvel can only do the MCU can only do
things with Sony's permission and vice
versa on some on I mean with Spider-Man
I mean MCU can only do things with
Spider-Man with Sony's permission on
screen and and the same goes the other
way if if you know Sony wants to do
stuff that doesn't include even include
Spider-Man and maybe they'll wanna have
the beyonder in this like in the
animated Spider-Man show when they had
the first spider-verse crossover and and
they and Sony doesn't have any rights to
that because to be honor isn't
necessarily a Spider-Man character so
they could be trying to do some sort of
deal so that way the MCU and Kevin feiny
can say hey uh Spider-Man 456 like let's
light up these villains and have the
story that fits in nicely with our
Disney MCU stuff and then Sony you can
have these toys and play with these and
work that way and do whatever you think
you want to do so I could totally see
that coming it would just be crazy if
again more Jonathan Majors I'm not
complaining I'm just like this guy needs
a day off he is in all the things
seriously man like imagine seeing like a
Jonathan major Spider-Man variant was
just like yeah I got the spider sauce in
me too
[Laughter]
he's already so hot that like when he
went through the transformation of
becoming Spider-Man and getting even
hotter it would just explode the the
Multiverse you want to talk about it
exactly some Madness let's see Kane get
hotter let's try seriously he would
probably absorb all the protein from the
great Web of Life and Destiny we just
like absorb all of it oh yeah the web of
life and Destiny would become like the
ABS of life and Destiny yeah he's
Moreland looking spider-verse yeah that
he he feeds off other spider people
that's what gives his body strength and
that's why he's so ripped this all makes
sense
that's hilarious
but I don't know what do you think about
this idea Jess
um
do I think it's likely to happen no but
do I like the idea
of King showing up I would love that to
be the merge they choose the into the
spider-verse to be the merge but it's
really weird because into the
spider-verse has over 1 000 people
working on it and I think they're more
gunning for an Academy Award than they
are for the Synergy between Sony and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right but what
I love the merge to start with Kang
absolutely uh I think I'm still on the
fence about like who's stronger Kane or
Thanos Thanos and so I'm like you need
to give more to Kang for him to feel
like the bigger bigger than Thanos thing
and that would make him bigger in my
opinion I just think and also I kind of
think I would rather see the high
evolutionary than I would see King in uh
and across the spider verse bro that
would be a real I like that idea of the
the high evolutionary being involved in
the Spider-Man movie because like you
know Spider-Man is like a sort of like a
next step in evolution he's like a
strong person and he seems to be a
multiversal constant throughout the
spider-verse so like I'm sure the high
evolutionary there like hmm let me get
some of that spotted spider sauce
no thank you who am I married James yeah
who am I Gwen Stacy no but I uh I also
think like half of those Spider-Man in
that Universe are like not actually born
spider like some are born Spider-Man
some are made by spiders yes but some
also just bought the equipment some of
them have altered themselves so I think
the high evolutionary being some more
spiders yeah oh high evolutionary look
at that werewolf and be like I can make
you better I can make it stronger I can
make you walk on two legs instead of all
four sprinting the monkey the monkey
Spider-Man he's like I could make you
less monkey more human the monkey's like
what
you want to do a Planet of the Apes come
with me no thanks that movie scares the
[ __ ] out of me I'm more I'm more
picturing like a George of the Jungle
scenario I'm imagining a Curious George
scenario so that's interesting
Curious George of the Jungle baby that's
the crossover we [ __ ] need
George George of the Jungle crossover
starring Brendan Frazier and the Man
with the Yellow Hat yeah the man of the
Yellow Hat is the real Ville not Kang
it's the man of the yellow hat at the
end of
Eternity he and Waldo have just been
teaming up for years to destroy the
Multiverse yeah yeah it was such a
stretch how did this land damn she
called that [ __ ] she called that yeah
I'll be the first one to yell I was like
oh [ __ ] yeah
I mean like the ancient one was
basically the Man with the Yellow Hat
because she bore yellow
and she was when she had that water that
she was a hood I was gonna say did she
have a hat but it was a hood yeah the
man with a yellow hat is more of a Vibe
less of a gender role situation
is there um more characters like King
are there any storylines from comics
where Kang and Spider-Man were very
important
hmm because that's also where I'm like
you could just throw King in there but
if there's Like An Origin to like
because like the high evolutionary
worked with Jessica Drew's dad so it's
like oh the high evolutionary is really
connected to Jessica Drew that's why
that's why one of my only problems with
this idea empty is because yeah like I
think if it was King it would it would
take the wind out of the sails of what
of what could make spider-verse unique
right like if we we have a chance to see
new stuff and and experience a new
universe of infinite possibilities and
if it ends up being Kang which we're
already kind of getting in Ant-Man and
we're gonna get it again in Loki season
two and we're gonna get it again in uh
you know in Avengers Dynasty whatever I
almost feel like wow well we could have
done something else but we're doing the
same thing again I guess that would be
my only you know one of my only things
where I'm just like uh well I mean I
could see it but I kind of hope it's not
because yeah it would be cool if it was
something different and even high
evolutionary would be at least we're
only getting that one other time you
know what I mean with yeah yeah with the
guardians but but like no I totally get
that um for sure and like you know I
definitely do like the uniqueness of the
spider-verse movies and like I mean if
they decide to like keep those 100
separate I would I would love that as
well however would you guys love the
possibility of seeing Miles Morales from
the into the spider-verse movies in
secret Wars and being an integral part
of that narrative that would be cool
like that'd be really fun to see like
him and like Gwen Stacy be part of that
um Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
narrative oh man you just gave me you
just gave an idea Mt what if uh will
they bring the animated miles into the
yeah into that secret Wars movie and
then he comes out the portal and they've
cast an actual person and now it's it's
the spider-verse miles not just any
Miles Morales it's the spider-verse one
that's now in the MCU and now live
action oh man that would be dope uh the
reason I like this theory is because of
what happened in Multiverse verse of
Madness where we saw America Chavez and
um
Doctor Strange like getting sucked into
all these different multiverses and one
of them was a cartoon world and we also
know in like in the spider-verse anime
like animated movies
um each like different spider verse has
its own animation style and we're
getting to see that like with Miguel and
Nueva York and then we saw that with
like Spider-Man Noir you know and uh so
I think that if we did see Kang it could
be him
getting [ __ ] bounced around the
Multiverse like a pinball in the same
way that Dr Strange and America were and
he could just happen to end up in the
spider-verse Multiverse and he would pop
out of there being an animated character
and then that way miles could like Tom
said pop out and be a live-action person
via the same Multiverse rules so yeah I
think this works no that's I like that
point for sure because like we saw at
the end of another spider-verse when um
when Spider-Man 2099 went into the uh
the OG cartoon Spider-Man yeah
it changed yeah exactly so you would so
Kane could come and he could still be
the Kang that is invading like the MCU
Multiverse same guy right different
animation style exactly and we sort of
saw that Multiverse of Madness when um
uh Professor Xavier was um basically the
X-Men 97 version of Professor Xavier
yeah so like you know yeah so like if he
was in a cartoon world he would look
like that you know like exactly you know
idea what if uh what if uh this is not
the Kang from the MCU but it's like a
variant just like he who remains who's
like another dangerous version of that
that still shows up that might be too
convoluted but that way you could you
could have him do whatever he needs to
do in spider-verse maybe get defeated
get you know get killed whatever but
then we still got Jonathan Majors you
know showing up later because it's all
about survival the fitness for the Kings
and Kang is the one I still think that
they could defeat him without killing
him though like he could like they could
like send him home like a little a
little bruised crying to his mama
without like taking him out and then
that would serve as like a reason for
him to like go ham on you know whoever
he's attacking next because he's like
God damn it I got my ass kicked by a
teenager and his friends like
the Conqueror yeah yeah and then he's
like I'll show them who the [ __ ] is
with these goddamn abs and then he's
right
Whitney's like don't kill him did you
see those abs because if we kill him the
ABS go away they'll still be here Wendy
they'll still be here yeah as long as he
can go be a person again if you die in
the Animated Series you die in real life
it's Matrix rules Freddy Krueger
yeah and such all the movie rules seems
like that Trope has been used over and
over again no way whoa you know I like
what Tom said about um like there being
like another variant attacking the
spider verse because I think that's
highly likely considering the ending of
locally and like they're them saying
that multiple experience were coming
locally it's
okay
I'm sorry that was just really cool
yeah that's a new variant Loki does uh
Nails uh anyway
um no it was from what we've seen the
Loki finale we know that there are
multiple variants heading to rec shop
and the Multiverse so like I would be
dope to see like I don't know like a
Scarlet Centurion version be the
spider-verse version that like it's just
like all right I'm gonna go beat up the
Spider-Man Because the skeleton turian
wears red like all the Spider-Man so I
think it'd be really fun to be like Oh
I'm also gonna be beating up these red
people anyway uh but no let's vote on
this theory about King the Conqueror
potentially cameoing in the spider-verse
franchise do you guys think it's gonna
be bogus I'll be sorry rogus bogus or
ogis let's start with Jessica
hit me I know I know what's coming it's
coming just hit me with it thinking
um good news
I'm thinking about it bad news okay it's
between an ogus or a bogus for me
yo hit me with that boat cause I can
take it I'm like the idea of it is very
rogus to me it's very Rogue Theory we
need to remember Rogue theory is
supposed to be the most backwards crazy
theories and I think this is a very
crazy freaking Theory
is it sound no
do I trust it no
hey I'll just give it a bogus
yeah I will take the bogus Big Time
bogus for Mt one bogus what you think
Tom I think that
just took the words right out of my
mouth but wait hold on oh I'm I haven't
decided yet
but like real talk I real talk I love
this idea I never thought of that and I
love and I love the Synergy behind it
but I I I I was thinking more on the
business end of it whereas like yeah I
don't know if Kevin feige is gonna give
their next biggest toy uh Kang to Sony
to use and you know in this movie that
would really energy is the most
businessy word in the world but it's two
different things
yeah but but you know I don't think but
Kevin doesn't have full control over
what Sony does so like by giving them
any keys or toys if you know Lord and
Miller the guys who made this Amazing
Spider-Man movie if they leave and Avi
Rod got the keys again or whatever you
know what I mean now we're back to a not
good situation with what Spider-Man got
I will have a Spider-Man 3 all over
again so uh so I so I was going for that
business angle but then I kind of a
story wise was telling convince myself
that maybe it wouldn't work because of
uh again we're diluting Kang as a big
bad like what made Thanos kind of huge
is that he's coming he's coming oh my
God he's and then somehow they landed
they'll suck the landing when they're
like oh [ __ ] Thanos is the real deal
he's here but if we keep having Camp I
already popped up with Loki and it's
gonna pop up in that man he's popping up
again in this by the time we see him in
you know we'll have by the time we see
him at Avengers if he's not as cool as
any of these other versions he's gonna
be a weak villain and so that from a
story Point that's where I mid mid
conversation with you guys I was like oh
you know what maybe that might work but
that might not work but again this is
Rogue Theory so we want to go ahead we
want to go Rogue but I was like I don't
know if that would work just from that
storytelling point of view so I'm gonna
go August though because I love the idea
and I I really like it and this is Rogue
Theory we're supposed to go Rogue but I
don't think it'll pop up and work
because of those reasons so there okay
no I thank you like that was a very
detailed reason for you I was thinking
about it this whole time I was like
think about this because
and I missed many times I actually
haven't even hit once but I was like let
me think about this so anyway in the
theaters what kind of shows up I'm gonna
be like Auntie was right I'll be the
first one to retweet rehab whatever that
you'll be eat screaming like exactly
yeah
Andrew was right if you guys see me in
the theater don't sit in front of me
because it'll just be Colonels just
flying up the screen being like that was
right Whitney was running somebody you
know how oh my God
what'd you think Whitney uh I'm sorry
Tom and Jess I hate to break it to you
but empty and I have an announcement
which is that this is uh the ending of
the third spider verse we wrote it and
you're excited that this is what's
happening I think it's cool what will
you do in part two then
don't even worry about it no I think
that he's gonna show up at the end of
part two so that's what I guess my
caveat is that if Kang shows up at the
end of part two that's how we get the
spider verse and the real yes
to intertwine like little snakes in love
uh that's what I want
just like he's slapping snakes so is
that is that a rogus yeah yeah it's a
road yes we just wrote the greatest
ending to be on the spider verse in
history suck it Lauren really just
kidding Let's Learn Billy you're great
you're great I'm totally joking we love
you guys so much you guys are geniuses
but I you know this I like having one of
each I feel like I collected all the
Infinity Stones
I'll give you an additional bogus
extra bogus more power but no thank you
guys for for listening to my theory but
up next Jess has a really amazing theory
about a pregnant Jessica Drew that's
very spicy and controversial but first
the holidays are just around the corner
and a great place to find something
special for the nerd of your life is at
new rockstarsmerch.com there are tons of
awesome new rockstars merch to check out
and if you're worried about knowing
someone's sizes they're a size agnostic
merch options for you to choose from
including hats mugs stickers and enamel
pins so support the channel and check
out all the awesome merch options over
at New rockstarsmerch.com and we want to
thank the folks at smile brilliant for
sponsoring this podcast and if you've
ever considered whitening your teeth you
might be confused by all the variations
of teeth whitening on the market
thankfully smile of brilliant is here to
explain the science behind teeth
whitening to make you feel comfortable
about choosing the correct method stop
the expensive gas and test match method
when it comes to teeth whitening and
Oral Care many of the at-home products
on the market don't even work as
intended LED lights are a novelty item
strips neglect the gum lines crevices
and molars often making remaining stains
that will be more prominent plus strips
use hydrogen peroxide which always
results in Greater tooth sensitivity in
comparison to carbamide peroxide
charcoal is abrasive and wears down the
enamel and whitening toothpaste only
works on Surface stains and like
charcoal is abrasive so what works the
number one product recommended by
dentists is fitted tray historically
dispensed only by dentists at a price of
three hundred to one thousand dollars
that changed more than 10 years ago when
smile brilliant came up with the
Innovative lab direct process head on
over to smilebrilliant.com and get
custom fitted teeth whitening trays or
night guards if you grind your teeth
they also have a whole Suite of
professional oral care products such as
an electric toothbrush water flosser and
dental probiotics and much more and
right now they're having a holiday sale
with discounts up to 50 off the normal
price so freshen your breath and look
with code Rogue five and save an
additional five percent on their holiday
sale that's Rogue five at
smilebrilliant.com and we also want to
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode the holidays may be all about
red and green but this year why not add
a little blue and I don't mean sad blue
I mean blue too blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you could take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
head or be ready whenever an opportunity
wink wink strikes the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com and consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers these are not unlicensed
people they are licensed and once you
are approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations about
boners and no waiting in line at the
pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package
sometimes it takes a little more than
mistletoe to make the holidays more
romantic and blue shoe is here to help
so if you can benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
chew it and do it have better sex with
blue Jew and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try Bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code Rogue at
checkout just paid five dollars shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code Rogue to
receive your first month for free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast all right guys it's time for
Jessica the amazing theorist the roguest
of us all all to give us our second
topic for today Jessica Clemens take it
away
[Laughter]
exactly the rogus of the ball today you
can't buy at the mall oh hey we gotta
release an album right now
my theory
which I
will shoot down first
um
I love the theory I love the theory I
love the theory and I am actually
someone actively that hates when people
not hates when people I don't ship
people in movies all the time live
action I don't really care about that's
the reason why I'm shooting down my
theory because my theory is actually
that Jessica Drew is pregnant with 2099
Miguel O'Hara's baby now we know that
we're gonna see a pregnant Jessica Drew
we saw it in the trailer and we've seen
a lot of other instances in the trailer
where we have Miguel and her just kind
of like near each other and they're it's
I don't know maybe it's just me I'm like
why are they such a close team already
um after the trailer dropped there's a
trailer q a after party with the
producers in hailee Steinfeld mt's
partner and
and they discussed how
um Miguel has a sort of spider force and
that
um I assume Jessica Drew was probably on
that since Gwen is a part of that and
Gwen looks up to Jessica Drew as a
mentor and I think Jessica Drew and
Miguel O'Hara have closer than a spider
Force friend Connection I think they're
actual partners that both have lost
something very important to them in
their Universe have found the Comfort
within each other and now we're gonna
get into the storyline of how the world
can exist or the universes can exist
with a multi-universe baby because we
know that they can't technically live in
each other's universes and Mt and I
talked about this on inside Marvel about
how the bracelet is going to stop the
incursions from happening I think
incursions can still cross over to what
the Sony universe is so I think these
people are existing with the bracelet so
they're gonna have to make a mini of the
version of those bracelets for the baby
so it can go between both universes but
they can't that's also if the universe
is complete or that's if the bracelets
actually work and are ready for like a
baby that is like The Offspring of two
people from two different universes two
different realities because Jessica Drew
isn't Spider-Man and Miguel O'Hara isn't
or like Jessica Drew isn't Peter Parker
and neither is Miguel O'Hara they're
both two different people so I think
this is a ridiculous idea but I think we
should get into the actual Theory and
open the door of what would happen if
the universe is collided and they had a
baby between the two how can that exist
uh question real quick are you talking
about what to say incursions do you mean
universe is colliding or because or them
kind of like glitching because that was
the I think I thought I was thinking
they had those wrist things because it
kept them from glitching out in Another
Universe right but it might be for both
is what you think yeah I think it keeps
them still so those like vibrations of
glitching
um is what it's like you're gonna die in
this universe because you're not
supposed to be in this universe but I
think those bracelets will stop them
from doing it oh and so their baby maybe
if they don't belong to either will like
oh damn they'll be heavy I don't know I
don't know if it'll exist only in that
Spider-Man plane where they're like safe
zone is but I genuinely I couldn't find
any answers about a baby being born by
two people from two different universes
that are of the same
character like what animation style
would it be yeah like what animations
it just comes out as doodle bop
SpongeBob it's like
okay
we should have not had a beef oh my God
what if he does come out is just like a
rough line drawing and he has to grow
into his animation style oh my God he
gets more and more cooked like a person
that I'd be the theater be like just
what that's right there's a doodle baby
on the screen I don't it's a doodle they
could easily just be friends and I would
support it if they are just friends I
just think that idea of having a baby is
insane they're just friends like like BJ
Novak and Mindy Kaling are just friends
okay
okay I know you guys are sexually
interested in each other I know y'all
like that was the thing was like I was
like
okay so the spider Force team that we
know of so far is spider Gwen a hobby
Hobart uh Daniel Clue's character and
which are their match made in heaven
they're two rockers they're too freaking
like one plays a drum one plays the
guitars they're punk from the 60s just
Avril Lavigne and Gerard Way together
those two together absolutely not but
and so like it already like written like
how like if there's a romance story it's
like those two and those two right by
the way I also thought when you said
spider Force for a second I was thinking
like the force so I was like wait they
confirmed that McGill hair has a force
like a spider Force Power oh there's
this movie's gone Oh you mean like team
oh God you're a team okay
if the Multiverse baby needs to wear a
bracelet or else it just Jack Jacks all
over the place because it's the flowers
are just like
and like so the baby can like portal hop
and the baby can light on fire
he's a child of many multiverses
before I break your heart they already
said that storyline is happening to
Peter B Parker's baby Mayday because
they already cat the baby is already
appeared so you're gonna have a Jack
Jack you're gonna have a Jack Jack it's
just gonna be May Day the baby no I I
like this idea of their this being like
a uh intermingled interdimensional baby
because like you could be the girl super
wrong as in like the baby doesn't belong
anywhere so like the baby needs the
bracelet at all times but it could also
be like the baby is now immune to the
effects of the spider version can now
travel yeah without the bracelet they
just go anywhere so like this baby super
special
um so that
I like your idea more because now
thinking about the bracelet that seems
like a horrible idea because the baby
could just blast itself like America
Chavez into a different reality and to a
different universe and disappear forever
uh so oh there maybe could be America
Chavez either way uh either way I think
yeah I like your idea more I'm gonna I'm
gonna take that one no like this idea of
like there being in like a a
interdimensional baby from like both
worlds I think it'll be really fun
especially if we know like because I I
don't if you guys were in the uh the
spider-verse comics right like the
original series like there's that great
Loom guy and like there's a you see in
the trailer there's like some guy like
spinning a web in the the great Loom or
whatever I would love if like their baby
became like a spider verse staple like
basically just like all right I'm in
charge of like the the great Web of Life
and Destiny because like I'm an
interdimensional being so like now I'm
just gonna Ascend and like basically
manage the spider verse that'd be really
fun if they um if they sort of did that
yeah I I really like this um I really
like this idea too Jess I think that it
would give the movie a lot more personal
Stakes you know like if you're because
if you're watching it's just like you
know let's say spot comes out we gotta
fight him and beat him up I mean you
know that's not as exciting as as like a
smaller more intimate story where you
care about what's gonna happen and them
having a kid together would give them
both reasons to wanna you know fight for
fight for tomorrow and maybe that and
that would put them at odds with with
Miles if what he's doing is not getting
on board to make this happen or make the
world safe for this interdimensional you
know baby that they're gonna have and I
think it would also be interesting
because it would give it would give
miles and Gwen like not that they're
gonna have kids but if they're gonna be
in a relationship it might show them the
dangers of what that might end up being
if they want to have a life together
right if Miguel and Jessica are having a
problem and maybe they can't even be
together and so that all of a sudden
adds a lot more layers to this movie
where there's a lot more at stake than
just some Universe ending event which is
cool and all but like that these movies
are the these stories are a lot more
impactful when they're you know boiled
down to what to like a very personal uh
reason and story for each character and
that would be huge so that's a really
interesting fun idea I didn't think
about and especially because his first
daughter died so he would just be like
hell bent on being like this baby will a
be born and B not die on my [ __ ]
watch like not again you know not again
and if there's some like maybe this baby
is the key to surviving and or traveling
the Multiverse without any special
device or equipment and maybe so that's
why villains are after it because if
they you know if they can get like in
the last of us if they can figure out
what how she works or you know how the
baby works then they can you know use
that technology you know what I mean uh
against the spider people or something
like that so that's really cool too that
I really like that like um that idea as
well like it's like we need this baby
blood to be able to travel the the
spider verse we need this baby blood
we're coming
[Applause]
I really like what Whitney said about
um you know the Spider-Man 29.9
seemingly losing a child because we've
seen the trailer that um he has a
daughter or um that he he seemed to have
lost and I think that even if this baby
isn't
um Miguel specifically I would love if
the movie ended with Miguel and Spider
Woman be getting together and like him
being the father of the baby sort of
like replacing that yeah he might not be
the dad but he might be the dad who
steps up exactly I think that there's a
chance that Spider-Man 29 might be one
doing a Kingpin in this movie and
wanting to get a variant of his daughter
and like you know
um miles in the Gwen are like you can't
do that we're supposed to be the good
guys he's like you're right I'll just
have spider woman's be the dad who
stepped up for Spider Woman instead and
um I think that uh Rio Morales
potentially dying in this movie would
give miles the responsibility to be like
all right I would like to save my mom
but I can't because we have to be
responsible in Spider-Man 29 is gonna be
like that's right I always have this
stepdad baby instead yeah
I guess I just missed step dad instead
of a real dad
and I was thinking about that idea
instead of the pregnant her being
pregnant with his baby I was like I was
trying to stay away
from her being like a single mom as much
as I could and I was like what is
another storyline that is really good
and I like the idea that like he lost
his daughter and now he's like you don't
know what it's like to lose your baby
yet like it's not gonna be worth it and
she's gonna be like I'm a grown woman I
can take care of my child like this is
not your child I understand that you
feel like she's like what do you mean
yet yeah
exactly
red flag
right there are you gonna kill my baby
yeah wait rewind what did you say yeah
but I think he's gonna he it's it's
gonna be that thing of like same with
like Peter B Parker he saw uh like he
started Living the actual Trials of a
dad when helping miles and into the
spider-verse and so I'm like oh he's
just gonna he's gonna see like how the
importance of a baby through Jessica
Drew's eyes pregnant right now and just
constantly be like you don't know I lost
my right my life's really hard and I'm
gonna I'm not trying to laugh I'm just
saying like that's what he's gonna yell
and she's gonna be like settle down I
don't know how she's like kicking so
much ass if I was pregnant I would be
horizontal a hundred percent 100 riding
motorcycles like kicking people in the
face with her tires
just riding my couch cushion I just feel
like this is
riding Dreamland just
eating a bowl of cold spaghetti and a
peanut butter sandwich foreign
[Laughter]
that's what happens when I'm pregnant
with a Chipotle burrito I'm just
horizontal for several hours I was gonna
say in that case I think I might be
pregnant now because I have a hard time
wake up every day I don't like leaving
bed my body always hurts so yeah oh man
the the delivery is always the painful
part it is yeah anyway uh best vote on
Jessica's theory on um potentially
seeing Miguel and Spider Woman having a
baby together do you think this theory
is rogus bogus or ogus starting with
Whitney what do you think Whitney oh man
okay I'm gonna give it between a rogus
and an ogus because August August
because uh sadly I don't
know if it'll this is I think this is
the first time you've ever given anyone
a half August rogus no I have who'd you
give another round
is going to be coming out before this
video but there was we shot a video
where it's all of the the things we got
wrong this year and some of the things
we got right that's gonna be a fun video
for you guys to look forward to but I
could not [ __ ] remember for the life
of me anything that I'd gotten right
because I just don't remember [ __ ] like
I just oh man and then as soon as I like
we finished filming it the next day I
was like going back through some old
theories and I was like oh wait I did
get some stuff right and I just didn't
just high all the time we're just so
smart that which is like you know I
don't remember all the stuff I got right
it just get so wrong and I can't keep
track yeah yeah yeah
but okay so like halfway between rogus
and August oh yeah sorry I think that
because I don't know if they'll do it
because I just feel I don't know I don't
know I don't know if it's a thing that
they would do that's why it's half
August because I just don't know but
rogus rogus because I'm sorry Mt this is
a way better [ __ ] pitch than She-Hulk
and Matt Murdock that one was dumb at
least this one like makes sense
it's true it's true for sure I think
that this would make a lot more sense
than she'll come back I love you and I'm
just joking I miss you too but what do
you think Tom uh well since uh Whitney
broke with me last time I have a break
with her this time I'm gonna give this a
rodents two rogus no that's not because
um I know I I love this idea I think
it's great and again it would give the
story and the characters a lot more
personal stakes and it would make things
matter as opposed to just like Hey we're
in this like spider world and oh there's
a lot of Spider-Man and Oh no you're
after me and oh there's a big bad guy
and the end it would just not it would
fall a little bit flat but having there
be like the stakes of this child of
theirs and and I also like the idea of
it maybe giving uh miles and when like
an idea of what a life together being
from two different universes would be
like how hard that would be and them
still may be choosing to be there that
would be really cool and that would be
that I would really like that so I'm
gonna give this to and it's Rogue as
hell so boom right multiversal blood
baby is Rogue as hell that is yeah
beyond the spider versus colon
multiversal blood baby
I'm the blood baby BBB the I'm gonna
give this I'm gonna give this an ocus
because like I do think it's Revenge yes
there's a possibility that we can see
20.99 and no bro I think there's a
possibility we can see 29.9 being The
Stepfather of Two Step uh Spider Woman's
baby for sure that I don't think that I
don't think necessarily that this baby
is the father I think that like the baby
might have a Spider-Man 29 father in the
future of stepdad but like not
biologically so I'm gonna give it like a
half half roguez genuinely I think
Jessica Drew is happily married and in a
happy relationship I don't want to keep
pitching her as a black single mom with
no no one I don't want to pitch that she
is I think she's happily married or what
if she is like uh oh God what's that
movie with Jennifer Lopez where she
chooses Anaconda to get pregnant without
a man
Anaconda no it's not Anaconda it's uh
marry me with Old Wilson I don't
remember what the movie's called I don't
watch a lot of JLo movies married in
Manhattan made in Manhattan
I said I was like she was like I'm
single I want to have a kid I don't have
a husband but that doesn't [ __ ]
matter because I'm gonna be an awesome
mom so it could be one of those
situations where she just felt felt
empowered to have a kid yeah but it's
still pushing that Trope of black women
that don't have fathers and that
horrible statistic of single black dad
just leaving and I don't want that to be
pushed now it's time for our Rogue
question are you guys ready to get Jay
Rogue in this yeah okay here we go
um because since this is the last Rogue
theory of 2022 I cannot believe this
year is over my God time has been taken
from us it's King the Conqueror
um I think it's time for some New Year's
resolutions guys is that because I want
you guys to come up with your roguest
New Year's resolutions for one of your
heroes or villains in any nerdy
franchise of your choice so it doesn't
have to be the MCU it could be DC it
could be stranger things it could be
um a owl house it could be anything
like for example like we were talking
about earlier
um Scarlet Witch could have the
resolution of not killing people
um that'd be a really nice Revolution
for your husband yes her husband don't
tangentially cause his death this time
um this is a fun one
um
uh uh you know that's I I'm going for
this because it's just the last movie I
saw I don't know if you guys have seen
violent night yes oh I haven't seen it
not yet but I do listen to David Hopper
yes yes and David Hopper
um
David Harbor David Harbor is his name
right yeah David Harbor yeah well Hopper
is this character yes yes yes
um he's not a spoiler if you know the
trailer but you know Santa gets into
some fights right and uh he has to stop
some bad guys so I would I I would say
that you know for his uh if I were him
my New Year's resolution would be like
maybe next Christmas maybe don't don't
get into killing anybody you know just
just deliver presents this year you know
let me just stick to my job let me just
try to you know but but you know if
people come if the wrong people come and
knocking you know I'm gonna take care of
it that's what he would do but but you
know like let me just because because
the whole the again not a spoiler but
the premise is like you know he's kind
of like J hated about Christmas and he
gets he swept up in the situation where
he has to help save uh this family and
so uh he didn't want this but he stepped
up to the plate and and so in the same
way it's like okay you know what maybe
next Christmas zero deaths by my hands
just let's just try that just deliver
presents be a good Santa let's go from
there so I'm gonna say that I like that
there's a general theme of no murder
right no murder next year 2023. you know
Santa's probably doesn't want murder on
his resume anyway but so this set of
particular is like let's just try to
have a normal Christmas next year let me
just get back on the wagon the magical
flying mic back on the non-murdery yes
let's just let me just get my reindeer
deliver some presents and then just just
eat home and go to sleep okay that's
that's a Do Your solution exactly I like
that what do you ladies think I does it
have to be fictional
is
James Cameron and try not to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I would have to agree uh that dude is
kind of like really really I mean like
James Cameron is a really great like
director like you can't even front but
like he's kind of I don't know his
rhetoric about the Avatar too I'm like
let's settle down let's wait until the
movie comes let's chill I just heard
this thing today that with if people's
phones went off on his set he would like
nail him to a wall or something I just
heard that today that and who's paying
for it who's getting me a new one I
don't know
the phone the phone
the person it's like oh I can't even
reply to my text because my ads mailed
until he crucified
crucifies the key grip
if your phone goes off the key group's
getting it again yeah the insurance on
James Cameron sets are probably so high
not only because of all this stuff he
does that is practical it's just because
he's gonna be like destroy him he's
gonna break some phones
give me that phone yeah
so the only thing I'm wondering though
is like because isn't maybe he's gotten
better and I'm not trying to defend him
but Kate Winslet has said she would
never work with him again but then I
just heard she's in the new one she's in
the new Avatar isn't she maybe she maybe
it's official starting like after she
she raps shooting she was like I'm never
working with him again yeah I thought it
was after Titanic where she's like never
again I thought and then now if I'm like
wait she's in this does that mean that
they've made up not to be a horrible
person not to be a horrible person James
Cameron's gonna make a lot of money from
that movie and okay Winslet will also
make a lot of money from them this is
true this is true it's a job you know
yeah she everyone they wipe their tears
away with the cash
that Henry cavill's New Year's
resolution is going to be to grow back
that sweet sweet mustache now that he's
a free agent and nobody's gonna take it
away from him with CGI not nobody not
know-how
I think that yeah 2023 let him grow his
mustache let him grow his stash back
he's been through a lot you've taken
enough from this man yeah
I love that you know what in the spirit
of of Henry Cavill I'm gonna give this
to Whitney because like I think that
he's gone through a lot and I'm gonna
give high wind to Henry Cavill because
Lord knows he needs one right now
I'm gonna give him a win yeah so give
him a win Henry Cavill wins this road
Theory everybody you're welcome Henry
you're welcome
you're welcome Henry hope this helps
expect you to be on the next episode
yeah exactly but that is it for this
episode of Rogue Theory thanks to our
amazing guest Jessica Clemens when
you've been letting him and Tom
Michaelson they are amazing friends I
love them so much please follow them on
Twitter and um and everything that they
do they're amazing people report our
Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me at
Max retainment on Twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] follow new
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube we love you guys so much and
we'll see you guys next time to get
Rogue see you guys later goodbye bye hi
[Music]